Село Залісся, Чортківського району.
Тут є печера Млинки.
Я сюди з шостого класу приїжджав,
з дому та зі школи тікав — вештався тут.
Вештався печерами, посадками, лісами.
Потім в Карпати більше. Сплави різні почались.
Може з 10 років назад, вирішив купити цю хату.
А на другий рік життя тут – вирішив остаточно
з Тернополя переїхати сюди жити, на цю глиняну хату.
Переобладнати її під туристичний притулок,
куди могли б приїжджати туристи.
Заробляти якусь копійку на тому.
Є печери екскурсійні: Кришталева, Вертеба.
Де можна в повен зріст ходити:
в костюмах, в одязі, в будь-якому взутті.
А в нашій печері треба раком, боком, повзати, лазити.
Є спортивні перелази, є тріщини,
розпори різні, дуже вузькі місця.
Від цього люди більше отримують задоволення,
тому що, певною мірою, то страшно.
Але коли самі долають, проходять –
отримують задоволення від того, що це вони самі подолали.
І таким чином – це більше приваблює.
Здійснює контроль та охорону печери Млинки
Чортківський спелеоклуб «Кристал», до якого і я відношуся.
Деколи йдемо в дальні райони,
щоб знайти продовження печер —
чи копаємо, чи дробимо,
чи каміння розбираємо.
Таким чином далі відкриваються
нові галереї, нові ходи.
Зараз печера має більше 50 кілометрів.
Вся робота — на ентузіазмі колективу
Чортківського спелеоклубу «Кристал».
До нас доєднуються інші клуби:
зі Львова, з Києва.
За рахунок цього ми й далі
можемо відкривати нові райони.
То є вхід у печеру Млинки.
Раніше місцеві люди добували цей камінь –
виробили такі каменеломні.
Зараз ми зайдемо у вхідні зали.
Звідси починаються у печеру лабіринти, ходи, тріщини.
Оце все – вхідні зали.
Тобто місцеві люди цей камінь видовбували,
починаючи з XVII століття.
Кирками, ломами, сокирами,
різними клинами видовбували цей камінь.
Потім вивозили тачками й підводами цей камінь
на поверхню. Там його випалювали.
Внизу, на тому потічку, вздовж якого
ми проходили, було три млини.
На одному з млинів випалений камінь крошили
і виходив такий білий порошок – алебастр.
Цим алебастром розмальовували
свої домівки ззовні та з середини.
Згодом винайшли вапно,
і ці розробки закинули.
Від того що були млини, назва потічка –
Млинки або Млиночки...
Ну і печеру, яку відкрили у 1960 році, йдеться
про природні ходи й тріщини, назвали також «Млинки».
З шостого класу я займався туризмом в Тернополі
в спелео-секції гірського туризму.
Мене привели для огляду цієї печери –
відпочинок вихідного дня.
Після першого проходження мені було дуже цікаво.
Згодом я домовився з тутешніми чортківськими
туристами-спелеологами, які прийняли мене в команду.
Вони навчили мене орієнтуватись в цій печері і любити її.
У інші печери їздили в експедиції.
В Крим – на вертикальні печери.
Так само разом з чортківськими
спелеологами ходили на спуски.
І з того часу я вважав себе спелеологом,
чортківським спелеологом.
Деколи люди губилися самостійно —
ми змушені були йти їх шукати.
Щоб таке не повторювалось,
тепер всі ходять з досвідченими провідниками.
Є й досвідчені туристи,
таким ми надаємо можливість доступу до печери.
За умови, що все буде культурно.
Тоді в печері буде чисто і гарно.
Тому печера Млинки зараз краще збережена.
Приїжджає багато людей, які були тут
у 1980-1990-х роках, і бачать позитивні зміни.
Тут чисто, і є доступ до печери.
Починається печера – вузько, слизько. Обережно!
Так, тут зараз буде вузько
і яма під ногами.
Над головою блиски вже більш такі кристалічні, гіпсові.
Мінімально, але вже сухіше в печері.
Вже сухіша печера.
Кристали на рівні рук більше замацькали – чіпали руками.
А от зверху вони збереглися більше.
Все переливається, виблискує.
Це так, як підземна казка.
На території нашого краю, Поділля,
було море, яке називалось Сарматське.
Досить мілководне,
й воно легко прогрівалося.
На дні того моря осідали
рештки рослин і тварин.
З часом вони пресувалися й кам'яніли.
Ці органічні відклади — скам'янілі.
Вони утворилися на дні цього моря.
Згодом почали підніматись
Альпи, Татри, Карпати. Гори рухались.
Так само і ця поверхня піднімалась, тріскалась.
І до цих тектонічних тріщин
проникала вода, яка вимивала цю породу.
Це наша місцева собака,
їй вже більше 10 років.
Раніше вона була сусідською,
але ми її приголубили, приласкали.
Також туристи її люблять.
Вона вирішила разом з нами жити.
Бігає з нами до печери,
чекає завжди, коли групи вийдуть.
Мені дуже подобається показувати печери іншим,
щоб теж «запалити», зацікавити цим людей.
А це все – об'єднує.
Потім з враженнями приходять
до хати або їдуть додому.
Однозначно відвідувачі
ще якийсь час згадують свої історії.
Вертеба – одна з десятків печер
західного Поділля в межиріччі Збруча та Серету.
За своєю геологічною історією та морфологією вона
абсолютно нічим не відрізняється від інших гіпсових печер.
Єдине, що до неї великий інтерес,
бо це є одночасно археологічна пам'ятка.
Печера є актуальною в контексті
дослідження трипільської культури.
Дванадцять років тому була укладена
угода про наукову співпрацю
між Борщівським краєзначим музеєм
і двома університетами США.
Студенти–антропологи мають нагоду
працювати в складі археологічної експедиції
Борщівського краєзнавчого музею.
Ми виявили ділянку печери,
де п'ять тисяч років тому люди залишили ці речі.
Ми там не досліджуємо,
ми її законсервували.
Речі, які залишили ніби вчора...
Ще цікавим є таке важливе наукове завдання,
яке стоїть перед дослідниками
трипільської культури й не тільки —
довідатись більше про носіїв, тобто про людей.
Адже ми говоримо про артефакти,
а не знаємо хто творив ці речі.
Коли ми говоримо про ці знахідки,
то завжди бачимо за ними людей.
В трипільській культурі так склалось історично,
що людських захоронень дуже мало.
Якщо вони є, то їх — мало.
А печера Вертеба дає саме такі матеріали.
Це були ранні землероби, які мали такий посуд незвичний
як біноклевидна посудина збільшених розмірів.
Ми бачимо антропоморфні фігурки –
тобто виліплені з глини і випалені теракотові вироби,
які зображують постать жінки.
В культі ранніх землеробів-трипільців
це була поширена практика.
Її завжди знаходять на розкопках,
на дослідженні таких поселень як обов'язковий атрибут.
Якщо уважно подивитися, люди палили вогонь.
Навіть залишився фрагмент долівки вогнища.
Долівка була затинькована.
Печера добре вентилювалась,
весь дим виходив на поверхню.
На даний момент такого немає.
Всі вентиляційні канали – закриті.
Вода розмивала печеру в різні боки.
Вода — головний архітектор, який збудував печеру.
Всюди ступала людська нога,
і немає таких технічних засобів,
щоб просвітити землю і сказати, де ще є печери.
Важко сказати, скільки відсотків ще
недосліджених печер на Поділлі, але знаю що багато.
І в такому напрямку теж при музеї діє об'єднання
любителів-дослідників печер.
І ми досліджуємо ці печери на всій території.
Є пропозиція внести трипільську культуру
до попереднього списку культурної спадщини ЮНЕСКО.
Печера Вертеба також в той перелік потрапила.
Можна багато про це говорити,
можна на цьому піаритись.
Але справа в тому, що потрібно просто брати лопату і копати.
Треба брати тачку і вивозити сміття.
Треба брати тачку і засипати ямки на дорозі.
Тоді ми будемо мати внутрішнє задоволення від того,
що ми щось зробили на цій землі.
Я так вважаю!